hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from the Grantchester
it's the Blitz edition of the of the
Tata Steel India with it vs. neppo it's
a really interesting game a lot we have
requested it and for good reasons so
let's check it out
without further ado with it opens with
Knight to f3 and all of you said that I
should have mentioned in at least some
of the videos that in the beginning of
the fifth day well the second day of
blitz Magnus and visited ruder game in 5
moves Magnus had had the white pieces
and unmov'd 5 Magnus offered a draw and
we did accepted Magnus said later that
he had stomach issues and that he just
didn't feel all right
I don't think of it it was aware of this
he just accepted the drop I don't think
I don't think we did accepted the draw
for no reason I don't think anyone would
accept a draw on move 5 but it is the
world champion though that's a that's a
free half a point and well he might have
felt something that something was off
and that's why he accepted it's hard to
say but there now you know and it's not
well as it is being played in India you
don't I mean you need time to you know
adjust to the climates to the changing
in food so it it's not so uncommon that
someone would would feel like that like
11 11 pretty much lost every game in the
wood section he lost over 50 rating
points so it definitely took a bigger
toll on him and if we remember when we
were showing a Paul Morphy game or
something like that when Murphy was
traveling by boat and then he would
reach somewhere and then he would
immediately go and play chess and he
would have a well not a bad result he
would still beat everyone but it
wouldn't be a clean Morphy you know just
annihilation but then the second day
when he got better then he just
obliterated everyone so yeah
yeah that that being said now let's
check out the game video opens with
Knight to f3 the rate is on the board
with c5 c4 and now Knight to c6 we
ignite the c3 and the g6 now preparing
to finca to the dark square Bishop with
III
and Knight to f6 we have d4 so this is
everything standard C capture son before
I capture son d4 and d5 we have C
captors and e5 Knight captures and now
Queen to b3 putting pressure on the
night here so nepo defends with east six
and now Bishop to b5 preparing to
capture on c6 which will mess up black's
pawn structure and create some weak
points on the Queen side but on the
other hand a nipple gets to keep the
bishop pair with Bishop to g7 neppo
prepares the castle captures captures in
the now we have castles napal also
castles and here rook to e1 so here
like I said nipple still has the bishop
pair if this bishop can find a nice
diagonal maybe such as this one then
then both of both bishops will be on
nice diagonals and the de bishop pair
will should be fully operational we have
Queen to distance by nipple and the now
Knight to e4 kicking the Queen back and
we already had this position onigiri
headed against mama D are off in last
year's status till now but in Vikon zip
and that game ended in Giri winning the
game but mama Dara replied with Queen to
b4 and then Giri stepped back with the
Queen with Queen sits the Queen to c2
but here we have Queen to c7 it is a new
move by Neto and it is as a move 13 that
we have a completely new game so Vedas
continues he develops the Bishop Bishop
to d2 he's expecting rook to b8 so
Quinta a3 might be you know joined with
Bishop to a5 to attack the blade black
queen with rook the b2 not that
b8 not that the bishop has been
developed the Queen can't really go far
because the b2 pawn would hang so Queen
to a3 and now f6 again one of the
positions where it's okay to play f6
takes away the e5 in g5 squares from
White's Knight also prepares g5 and the
expansion on the Kings side we have rook
a to c1 and now comes g5 with h3
preventing the instant the g4 also
making some room for the King and h5 by
Neto and here
Bishop to a5 like we discussed so the
Queen is under attack
Queen to d7 getting out of the way and
not nice to c5 attacking the Queen also
with a double
on the e6 pawn as the rook also attacks
that we have Queen to f7 and now Knepper
wants to increase sorry if it wants to
increase the pressure on the e6 pawn
which is a backwards pawn so you kind of
hope it it will be a weakness for a long
time
rope the e4 he wants to play rook C to e
one and create more threats against the
east exponent here Napo takes this
opportunity as now the rook is in an
awkward square with Queen to g6 now you
cannot capture on e6 because the rook
would hang only the knight guards the
rook here and also it prepares the
advancement of the Jeep on so the Queen
will nicely support the pawn we have
rooks e2 e1 now ready to capture any six
but now g4 now you have to react to this
we have H captures H captures and now
Knights the d2 will be a bit too slow
because f5 then comes immediately so
first night the h4 comes with an attack
on the Queen but Queen to h5 now
attacking the knight with g3 and f5 now
pushing the rogue back and here well you
have to move the rook otherwise you're
gonna lose it so rook the e5 you could
also go rook the e2 and then giving it
for the move but with it says I'm just
gonna play rock e5 and the next move I'm
gonna capture the e6 pawn and if you
want to give up your rook Bishop well
it's a it's a really important piece
your your dragon here is doing wonderful
for the defense of the black king but
Nippo says it's not a problem nipple
captures Bishop captures on e5 we have
rook captures on e5 and now Queen to h6
so with idea sort of infiltrating with
Queen to c1 check so videos prevents
this Knight to b3 not the knight nicely
blocks the C 1 square and also the
knight supports well kind of prevents
this pawn being pushed all the way to f4
and it is interesting you could try it
but well the only reason why it doesn't
work is Bishop to b2 now you cannot
capture or advance the pawn and white
will just pick up the point so that's
why it doesn't work here we have Bishop
to e6 pineapple now attacking the knight
here are trying to get rid of the
defender of both f4 and c1 and here
video goes for Bishop to d2
it does
it does eliminate the bishop on e6 also
well it's basically a trader but the
problem is that the Napa schooner will
be able to infiltrate so here neighbor
says okay Queen captures on d2 we have
Queen captures on a6 and now nepo
needs to go rook to f6 he needs to
prevent this point from being captured
also there are ideas of just rook
captures on b5 after one point captures
then the Queen can capture the other one
and then for example get to g6 so you
really need the rook on the sixth rank
but here instead neppo proceeded with
the attack with f4 and this just doesn't
work because it allows the visit rook to
g5 which he plays Knepper replies with
King to h8 you don't want to go anywhere
along the seventh rank because Queen
captures on 87 that would quickly end
the game so keep the h8 bennetto
and now feel free to pause the video and
try to find the winning move for with it
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations and finding well such
such a nice move and for those who just
want to enjoy the show it's nice to g6
check now you might be thinking why are
you asking us to find Nagi 6 check its
well it's fairly obvious everyone saw it
yeah well not everyone and well again
for good reasons because it does require
quite some calculation because after
this check the point is not to capture
the rook here the point is if the King
goes anywhere yeah well like the H file
then you just get Queen captures on a 7
with check King h6 and now Knight
captures on f4 that's the point now you
have the threat of checkmate and it's
impossible to prevent this whatever you
try let's say you prevent it this way
then just rook h5 is mate since the
Queen covers the g7 square you cannot go
there one of the reasons and another one
is after Knight to g6 check if you go
King to g7 it's a bit different but not
all that much still to get Knight G
captures on f4 it's important to
eliminate the DF for pawn also it comes
with a discovered check so King f6 now
you get rook captures on d5 and this is
move that was hard to find that's why
Knight to g6 was was not all that simple
to play so here doesn't matter if this
pawn captures or is it is if this pawn
captures if this guy captures then Queen
captures on e6 if this captures then
Queen captures on c6 would check not
much different and now you can go either
to g7 or to East 7 let's say we go to e
7 then it's just well Quinta East 6
check once you move the King King the
8th Queen to d6 check and now after the
King moves you can let's say pick up the
rook with check and now you're even up
material and of course you were you will
very quickly checkmate in the black king
so that's one way to do it after Queen
to c6 if you go to e7 if you go to g7
still doesn't really change all that
much when g6 check King h8 and now you
get knifed e6 threatening mate and again
there's very little you can do here so
if you block you like even Queen to h6
is made but a lot of very different well
not h6 because obviously the the Queen
can win and the White Queen but Queen h5
check forces black lose the Queen and
then it's made so only one one of the
reasons yeah so after King to h8 night
g6 is winning for a visit but a visit
place Queen cat force on h7 idea being
well Queen g7 will just be made so let's
let's just deliver that but it doesn't
work now vid it plays a move that
completely loses the game now feel free
to pause the video and try to find it
it's actually a forced mate in 8 4 nepo
so I'll give you a few seconds if you
want to try and find it
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations on finding either one of
the most well the second move is the
crucial one if you find the second moved
and everything ends in mate but it's
going to be one check I know you all saw
this one as it's the only useful check
you can give King to g2 and now the move
you have to find night the e3 check it's
very important to allow rook captures
and b2 to come with check because you
cannot afford any move to come without a
check because Queen to g7 is made so
what can you do here if King to h2 it's
very interesting because again you can
follow up with check and after
white captures again you get this route
capture some video with check and now
you're just well made meeting white
so after 93 check with it accepted the
night but now we have rook captures and
b2 check even giving up the rook now the
Knight captures that we have night cap
for Sun b2 and here again continuing
with check very important f3 check now
if you move the King King eh - it's not
a problem it's still a force made the
Queen e2 check King each one Queen the
f1 check you'll go King h2 now Queen the
h3 check forcing the King the g1 and now
finally Queen to g2 will be made not not
just yet but sorry not going to G to F 2
will be made so there you have it no
idea why plate Queen - G - so after e f3
check with Knight captures on f3 saying
that ok let's give a give back some
material but it's without without any
merit here never just played Queen
captures on f3 and it was in this
position that we did resigned the game a
sense whatever he does King h2 or King -
g1 he's getting made on both accounts if
King H - you're just gonna go Queen - E
- check and now the rook enters the game
King g1 or King - h1 doesn't really
matter just look - f1 will be made so of
course with it Saudis and after this
Queen captures an f3 he resigned the
game which is very unfortunate for him
since he also had a very nice meeting
scene sequence but yeah that's that's
why I thought it was a fitting title you
know if it wasn't losing he'd be
completely winning so I do hope you
enjoyed that along with the game I would
like to thank Stephen green and David
Compton for a contributor to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing maybe with
a few more games so we'll see if there
were some other nice suggestions if not
we're gonna check up on some other
suggestions and then we are ready to
start with our next big saga so far it
seems to be the Paul Morphy saga but you
can still vote on the stock saga the
link to the voting poll is in the
description below so you know go wild so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day